はい定義で今回はこちらランボールは111戸整備調査
ゲー
こんなにこの段ボールを使って何をしようかと言いますこれは
これが
保育園のときだったロボットが大好きでいつか自分で不在なロボットをつくってみたい
そう思って火付いたら23歳でしたどうすればお手軽に巨大ジョブを作れるかとぼくは
考えた末に思いついたのはランボールをつなげて頑張ってくっつければ巨大ロボットが
作れるんじゃないかと思ったわけです勝っすごいいい
名案ですねこりゃ払ってないぞこちらのダンボール100
10個つなげて上の理想のラボと作って
作ってみようと思います作り方なんですけども最終的には立たせたよロボット
どんなまま作っても誰かいることを作れないからまずはロボットを寝かせて作りまでて
いるロボット作ってそれをお通夜いいだなぁあの静岡のますよと結構贋造ぼんぼりだね
&ちょっとくっつければちょっと思っております v
まだダンボールを並べていくところから始めてみましたすいません
あと側に頭が揺れるこっちがもう片方難しい
これがつま先でぽいでしょへでも行くんじゃねうん
スタートだとすごいねぇとそう足首が作品になると思うんで走ってる奴が捕球していき
ます
4m の足が出来ました次はまたを作っていきますまぁ大体こんな感じでどんどん作っ
ていく作戦でございます
ちょっとアレが降りそうでマジ合わないので今回はこのロボットプロジェクトに参加し
ていただいてズル単位の皆さんに手伝ってもらうことになりました
ありがとうございました
ええええええ
だいぶ終盤に差し掛かってきましたロボット取りた目はほぼもん完成
あとは頭をつけるだけです
全長約
1メートル付ん
続きで前走者久住ずメートルのロボットが完成しましたこちらです
大峠ロボット賛成しましたのでぇ早速始動させてみようと思います
マーラ着ほど gxr 56000までです経って初めて成功ですからロボットは
いきます
このってばいい2 hey
ああダメかもしれないんだふりだと無理だったのでこの尾根また機は連れてちょっと
もう一回チャレンジしてみます行きまー
誰でも無理だったので3人でやろうと思います
定義なぁ
すいません少人数だと名な気がしてきたので6人で母に手伝ってもらいますほしいと足
に人入ってしっかり固定したまま体を押してみてますではにとってはイズナーいい
あっていきます
ああああああ
ています
ええええええ
dare
全体が例えば詳しいほしい
ここまではこれなんですよね
山みんなことに高さが足りないですせいぜいちょっと夏上げていませんはっはっは
n ame
それん
ran
場所だけだった
ああああああ